this is the kind of question we're
talking about okay this is the kind of
question with me and you'll see I will
actually already show you one of the
implications of this to go over here and
we'll deal with it in more depth when we
try those questions that we do lots of
practice so just like you have a point
of you here on over here right you can
divide them in just the same way you
divide numbers okay so let me remind you
how one religion with numbers works okay
off on the side somewhere separate okay
let's do a nun which is going to be
let's go say seven
that's tunable okay now how do we divide
numbers using long division when you
don't have a calculator or when you get
into a scenario where in calculators
you're not going to be very helpful okay
I've set it up I'm divided plan Purdue
by seven what's my first question what
do I do to that thing yes okay let's
also suppose you're doing like three
steps let's go in the first one and one
of the healthy times this goes into this
but I'm breaking it up into chunks
that's a crucial step the reason why I'm
doing this is so you see the parallels
over here okay the whole point would be
going through this algorithm is because
I don't know off the top of my head how
many sevens there are five hundred so I
approach a simpler question but just how
many seven time an in five okay not
there I'm going but you can't fit any in
there so that's why you write zero there
a confident event so they want to watch
what do I do next Mather validating the
view I appeal to the next digit right
and how many sevens can I fit into fifty
okay what do I do with that okay so now
I want to know I want to know therefore
after I've taken those seven cents out
what am I left with
okay so you get the seven sevens which
is 49
very good I wanted to learn after I take
my seven sevens out what will be left
out of the 50 and the answer is one will
be that there's a remainder okay I can't
fit any sevens into that but I have more
digits to access just like I use that
zero and hung on to the five I've got
another zero right here would you hang
on to this one okay I'm trying to make
sure you get the fact that this is not
just a process that you you pull down
the zero
why do you come down the zero because I
got told I pull down the zero right no
no the reason why is because you have a
remainder it's not really a midnight I
can fit more numbers into there okay how
many sevens go to ten so now I've
actually finished my division in terms
of knowing how many all lots of seven I
can fit into there okay because I have
no more numbers to appear to write you
see my actual number 500 to start okay
but I do want to do this last step so I
know what is left over because
remainders are important to me right
especially if they're zero so what am I
going to do now good so I put my seven
here because I want to know what's left
out of that 10 and the answer is three
is left right so I have my remainder
here okay
so keep that in the back of your mind
and let's have a go at this guy here now
it's called long division for a reason
it's long okay you're gonna need a bit
of base I'm definitely gonna need more
space than this so we're going to begin
exactly the same way and in case you
can't remember what all these things are
called this thing that you're dividing
up for those of you come as well right
it's something which gets shared out
into groups of seven right so that's
called a dividend which is why you get
paid out of dividends that's a thing
which gets distributed to people okay
seven is the thing that's doing the
dividing right like I'm dividing by
seven that's the action yeah so that's
why we call it the divisor
okay when you divide sorry when you
multiply you get product when you divide
you get pushes which is why we push it
rule okay so that's that there and of
course you already know what the last
pieces it's the remainder okay now what
am I gonna do with the polynomial I'm
gonna put everything in exactly the same
spot okay so I've got my demise are over
here I've got my dear the Damned over
here and then you're now gonna carry out
the algorithm so that I get my question
and my remainder okay now remembering
that the most important part here is the
X that negative one it matters but this
X should be like a million or a billion
right and this negative only pay off in
comparison okay so when I do the
division that's why I think mainly about
this guy and I don't worry about him
until later so how many X's might fit
into X cubed x squared right
and now the vs. begins right supply it
down or not do my subtraction so I'm
multiplying
do my subtraction now watch out for your
negatives okay
the negatives are the things that catch
people out in polynomial long division
which is one of the reasons why I'm
going to show you this method in case
you've never seen well so about x
squared and I'm gonna take away negative
x squared which leaves me with 2x where
it's a positive right I'm going to bring
the bite is to shoot X down and then I
posed the question again how many X's go
into 2x squared it's you guys yeah and
I'm gonna continue down so now what I
got here like 2x minus -2 X so that's 0
right so what do I do with that
now I already know I already know that I
can't fit any X's into that right so in
fact I've already ended up at my
remainder does that make sense like I
end up the remainder when I know I can't
go any further and I can't go any
further
yeah so there's my Reno you happy with
that I think it's important and the
reason why is for the reason I'm going
to show you in a second okay
what are we gonna do out of this one of
the great things we get out of long
division is you get a transformation
that you can make a statement that
relates your Divine's up dividend
quotient and remainder okay come back up
to about a numerical example up here if
500 divided by 7 is 71 remainder 3 okay
so I'm gonna say five hundred divided by
seven is 71 remainder three right what I
can do is I can say on the second I can
write 500 as equal to seven lots of 71
plus that remainder right which by the
way it's also how you arrived at mixed
new rules okay if I go back a step if I
write this as on seven on seven on seven
right that's how I know that five
hundred divided by seven is 71 and 3/7
that's how that's how we connect
two ideas together okay now I'm gonna
make the same statement but down here of
this polynomial okay so I'm going to say
if I take X cubed plus x squared minus
2x plus five
okay there's my dividend right it's the
divisor times the question plus whatever
was left over right just like I had
seven by seventy one plus three
okay so in this case what I've got is X
minus one here's my divisor x squared
plus three X as my question this is my
remainder hanging out are you okay with
that